welcome to PyCharm
my name is Richard Kirchner with the
simply learned team that's w w simply
learn comm get certified get ahead today
we're gonna be working with PyCharm the
Python IDE or user interface for
professional developers in the Python
scripting language for myself I like
PyCharm because it separates your
different environments and if you're
working in say Python 3.6 and you need
to code in 3.5 you can easily create
those different environments in the
PyCharm setup it also has a number of
wonderful tools to help you do your
different projects and to help you with
your coding we'll start from their
website
WWF brains comm slash pycharm
jeb brains is a company behind the
pycharm development even though pycharm
is open-source on this page you'll see
if you come to their main page and you
just do a search if you search pycharm
you'll find this as the top result
you'll see download now and it says
full-fledged professional or free
community version so if we go on the
download now button you'll see we have
the two choices unless you're doing a
lot of sharing and web development where
you're interfacing up into the web you
really don't need to pay for the
professional version if it's your first
time in start with the community version
and then as a company if you need the
professional version you can upgrade so
we'll go down here where it says
community we'll go ahead and click on
the download and then open and run that
just like you do any other install into
your computer and once you installed it
you'll see this icon on your desktop the
PC for pycharm icon I have it in my
Quick Start I'll go ahead and click on
that there and let it open up and you'll
see the PyCharm
opening up in the community version 2018
point three now
it'll load up the last whatever the last
project you worked on automatically and
then you can see here where it comes up
and has tips so you can go through some
of the tips and see some of the cool
tricks you can do you should also notice
on yours that the fonts and everything
are a little bit smaller I intentionally
a large mine for doing the demos and
tutorials and you can easily position
your workspace which I'm working here
and scratch three pi file they just
happens to be the last one I was doing
by default name them scratch whenever
you start a new file and you can of
course rename them and you will see on
this page there's three major well
there's a number may
areas they have on the left you have
tabs that you can go between you know
turns on and off things here here's our
project we're working on so I can make
it disappear if I don't want to have
this page open you'll see on the top we
have our standard file that of you
navigate and your different toolbar pull
downs your major icons in this case if
you have roburt of course it will tell
you that has open save you can
synchronize this with if you're working
on larger projects and you have the
professional version generally you'll
won't use this unless you're in the
professional version you also have like
your back or undo you'll see here where
I have scratch that's the one I'm
working on this tells it what it's
running so if I have multiple files I'm
flipping between I can easily run the
different ones or I can edit the
configuration from here also and then we
just have our simple run button you'll
see you if I hover over it it also is
shift f10 we have a debug it looks like
a little bug which is kind of cool and
we have our settings and we usually
start with the settings we can get to
settings here through the wrench you can
also go under file and you'll see down
here also settings and when we go under
settings we have appearance this is all
your setup you'll want to get into this
is where I change the font so it's nice
and large you can see I'm using size 24
font normally you only need it at 12 for
most of your work and there's a lot of
other settings in here you can change as
far as the look and feel of your project
you're working on in your interface how
you wanted to look at look you can also
adjust the appearance of your editor
down here with your different fonts
color Styles set up what menus you want
to show up there's a lot here under the
appearance and behavior that you can do
and also along with the editor we'll
come back to settings when we get into
our own project but for right now we're
just gonna look at the appearance in the
editor and you can change your fonts and
everything in there and we'll close out
of that other things to know courses are
open if you're opening up a Python or
folder you can also save if you go under
file there's the new scratch file that's
how I come up with a new scratch file in
our project your save over you open
recent there's a lot of different things
you can do in here you can also export
and import settings on whatever you're
working on we're going to start off by
creating a new project so the very top
selection under file is new project and
when I click on there you'll go ahead
and give it a name as untitled we'll
call
this pie charm tutorial well go ahead
and create that and ask me do I want
this window a new window attached or
cancel I'll go ahead and keep it in the
same window I could open up a whole new
window and project in here but I don't
need to I don't have anything in the
other project that I'm working on so I
can just let this take over and you'll
see it takes about about half a minute
for it to go through the creating the in
virtual environment and flashing through
all the different files is copying into
our new project and that's important
because whatever I do in this project is
separate from my other projects that way
if I have certain imports or certain
modules I've added in I can track what's
being used with this project and then if
we're going to deploy it I'll be able to
let the our admin on the server side or
whatever is going be able to bundle
those and deploy those now at this point
we want to get jumping on our
programming get started and writing our
script for Python and you can either go
up here to our project folder and right
click on that and if you go up to the
top you'll see new and you get a lot of
different options new scratch file new
file directory Python Python file you
can also get to this by going under file
and you'll see new or you can use the
alt insert any one of those will take
you to the same window and again we want
to select the Python file since we're
writing a Python script and we'll go
ahead and do a PI charm we'll just call
this pi charm in the Python file and
I'll click OK on there so now I have an
active window up in the middle you'll
see my PI charm on the left underneath
the project pycharm tutorial and I
didn't mention it yet but there's also
Python console terminal and to do on the
bottom let's go ahead and write some
basic code let's go ahead and import
math so we'll do a little bit of math
here and from import math we'll do x
equals minus 0.75 and you'll see that as
we're doing this stuff highlights and
appears and so I can do print and lets
me know what the actual code is and
let's say I'm doing absolute value I
want the absolute value of X you will
see it appear there on the top and I can
either hit the enter key or I can click
on it and if I click on it it does
absolute value and we'll type in X and
it even shows me that X is on my list so
there's X and now that we have all that
let's go ahead and run the code
and the first thing you notice is our
run button is not highlighted and this
thing says add configuration now I can
click on here and add configuration and
I can tell it what I want to run but I'm
very lazy
so we'll just go up to the Run button
across the top on the pull down you'll
see run which is also alt shift f10 and
if I click on this run it'll ask me what
I want to run and I want to run my pie
charm that's the name of the pie file
and so I'll click on that and then it'll
pop up and we'll hit run on there you
should notice that my configuration has
now changed to PyCharm up here on the
top and now I have my Run button so if I
ever need to run it again I can just
push this button and it'll know that
that's the last one I'm working with and
that's what I should run and this will
reset each time you create a new project
because you're now in a new environment
that way you can do additional
configuration in there and then we're
gonna bring it down here and I want you
to notice on the bottom it's
automatically I just put a big arrow on
here here it is PyCharm it's opened up a
pie charm and it's opened up a run tab
down here I can now easily get to the
output on this and you can see that the
output of the absolute value of minus
0.7 is 0.7 and it says process finished
and with exit code so it's hit the end
of the file and is done and if you're
looking at these tabs down here and I
said it's gonna come back to them you
can see there's the terminal so if I
want to put terminal commands in here I
can actually just look as if you're in
the terminal user interface I can print
hello enter and this is actually the
terminal for this would be if you're
doing something like pip pip install
that kind of thing underneath the
terminal and you can see there's a
Python console and the Python console is
just like this you can type in your
straight Python commands so if you
wanted to do something like that and hit
enter you'll see that print hello and it
prints hello but we're under the run and
so we printed our we've headed up here
this runs the script and let's say we've
had long code and we've decided that
after X and then we had X 1 and X 5 and
new X and old X we decide we don't want
to call this X we want to call this
something different well we can
highlight the X or whatever variable it
is we can right-click and this is an
important thing to know can very easily
refactor now refactor is a little
different than just changing the
renaming
refactor goes through your whole code
and changes X to whatever you want it to
be and so will instead of call this X we
just want to call this Y and we'll
refactor the Y and you'll see it changes
Y throughout our code so now we've been
working on our code for a while and we
imported math but what if we wanted to
import numpy as in p our numpy array and
we've got our code here we'll say that
we have new array equals in PE array 1 2
3 4 and if you've done this before you
know that if you're on your computer and
you've never run the numpy array before
this is an external module numpy is so
if I go up here and I run this now it's
gonna come up and say import numpy is in
P module not found error no module named
numpy so we're looking at this we can
either go underneath the wrench for
settings or under file and settings and
we talked about the appearance in here
and your editor and how you can adjust
all that for different luxe there's also
the project in version control so we go
into version control and use a lot of
different options here but we went under
the project and under the project
there's a project interpreter so if I
wanted to work on something other than
in this case Python 3.6 I can easily
switch this right now I just have 3 6
installed on this setup on this
particular machine but at some point I
had to seven for old older projects and
3/7 is a new Python that just came out
which doesn't work with the number of
modules so you can easily switch what
python you're working on to see if it
works with the different modules and
you'll see down here where it has the
package also and it has pip and setup
tools and on the right-hand side it has
the plus so we can add additional
modules in here and in this case we want
numpy so we'll type in numpy at the top
and they'll come down and you'll see
there's numpy and then there's a lot of
different other versions of numpy for
doing special things there's number
turtle numpy display and so on we want
just the basic numpy and so when we
click on the numpy we can now install
the package and this will copy numpy on
to this environment so this numpy is now
only in this project that way if you
have another project you don't want to
have to reload all your different python
tools you just want the ones for that
specific project you don't have to worry
about that and you can see where pops up
down here it says package numpy
installed successfully so I'll go
close out of this window and now you can
see I have numpy in my packages one of
the downsides of having such a robust
package like PyCharm which has all kinds
of settings as you can see there's build
settings there's languages and
frameworks there's tools is the most
basic things you need to know where
they're at and so your project setup and
project interpreter are one of the most
important things to be able to find
right away and of course your appearance
so it appears correctly so what's the
use of having a nice IDE if you can't
adjust it so it fits your needs
we'll go and click OK out of here and
then we'll come back in here to our PI
charm and it'll go back up here and hit
the run and you'll see now process
finished and we don't have an error no
if I'm done I can always go up here to
file I can close the project and then we
can go back up here and we can go to
open project or I can just exit out and
go back into the software and then we
can always go under and open a file we
can either click on the icon or file and
open and then browse for a file let's
say I want to I'm over achiever so I
want to open up another project I'm
working on or just did and I have the
option of opening this up in a new
window so I can replace my pycharm
tutorial with my object orientated
programming or I can open it up in a new
window and this is nice because now I
have the two windows and if I'm working
on in this case you'll see classes I can
now flip between the two screens and I
have two separate interfaces that I'm
going through
we'll go and close this one out and then
we already talked a little bit about the
configuration I can edit these
configurations we can save the configure
with let's go ahead and edit the
configurations and you can see in here
it opens up our pycharm our pride charms
set up and we also looked at how to get
through this through settings this is
just a quick way to get to it is this
one here with your configuration set up
and you can see here it's running the
pycharm py that's the script we've
chosen that's the name of this
particular folder or this particular
file
pycharm py and you'll also see you can
change your Python interpreter here it's
same as we did any settings and we have
the three seven there's my three six
environment three six REE so I have a
lot of different options as far as which
environment to choose from and we
already talked about a number of ways to
run it you can go into run and run it
from up here there's our run you can
click on the run key if you hold your
key over there you'll see that you
also running using shift f10 that will
run it and another option is you can
right-click on this space and also go
down here to run it's always good to
have your code actually do something so
we'll come down here and do print new
ray we can run it this way you'll see
down here prints are one two three four
and let's also do a print goodbye
French hello and one of the nice things
you can do with pycharm is we can then
on this left spot here click and add a
red dot which is a break point and this
time instead of running it we can go
through either under the run you'll see
debug charm you'll see this little bug
here we can right-click it and find our
picture of the bug down here in debug if
you hold your mouse over it you'll see
shift f9 so when we run this it'll come
through and it will go ahead and it just
stops here at our breakpoint and then we
end up with our variables showing what
they are the modules in PyCharm and you
get a lot of information and so it's
loaded the new array we now have the new
array in here and if I push f8 that will
continue to run you can also if you
hover your mouse over here you'll see
the debugger you can also stop PyCharm
where it's at so if we hit the bugger
again it'll continue stop and rerun
cancel if we go into run you'll see
debug also here set up the stop pycharm
but the key is f8 and when I do f8 it
goes down to the next one so it's gonna
print hello
and then I hit f8 again and hit f8 again
to get to the end of the program let's
go ahead and write a short script up
here we're gonna create like a small
matrix it's a simple list of lists and
we'll do an input so we can get some
values into it I'll say let's do enter x
and y and then if we're gonna have an
entry we should have x and y and this
will be an array I'll do integer X or X
in string split comma so what this does
is we're gonna generate an x and y
variable here so if I run this it will
prompt me down here and our input and
it's looking for like 3 comma 4 now if I
run this with something that's not an
integer because we have an integer we're
going to convert X each of those to an
integer
so if I put in a comma B it'll give me a
value error because it doesn't know what
to do with a comma B then let's go ahead
and create a list we'll have our list
equals call it list and then we'll have
let's see 0 for column in range Y now if
you remember from range that's 0 up to
but not including the Y value so if you
enter in 3 that 0 1 2 we're going to
assign a 0 for each one of those but we
also want to do that for row in range X
and so we can do here as we'll do so
right now if we run this and we just
print list which you can do we'll run
that enter x and y we'll go ahead and do
3 comma 3 and you'll see it creates a
list of 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 so we want to
go ahead and change that we'll do four
row in range X and there's so many ways
to do this we could have just as easily
done for value in well we'll do it this
way for a column in range Y and we're
gonna set our list of row and column
equal to some other value and we'll just
do row Times column so we should end up
with a row will have like a 0 times 0
with 0 times 1 0 times 2 1 times 100
times 2 and we can do a print like we
did before that's one option so we can
just print list and we'll go ahead and
run that let me resize this window so
you can see a little bit or what's going
on down below we'll stick to our 3 comma
3 and you'll see that we end up with 0 0
0 0 1 2 0 2 4 just multiplying them that
can be really hard to read and so a lot
of times in my own code I'll do
something like this I'll put that when
I'm troubleshooting things I might
reformat it to do the same kind of row
and column thing for column and range of
Y and then we'll just simply print in
this case list of row of column and if
you run this this will come out let me
just go and run this there we go we'll
enter in let's do 3 comma 3 and you'll
see that it puts out each value coming
down 0 0 0 and so on these could be very
complicated values they might not just
be a number another trick we can do this
I find myself doing regularly also is
instead of doing each individual maybe I
need to look at the room
to figure out what's going on with my
rows and you can see here if I type in 3
comma 3 I'll end up with each row coming
across and this is just simple
manipulation of a basic list with sub
lists that's all that is now one of the
especially in the data science realm one
of the most important things to start
doing is to plot what you're looking at
I don't know how many times this has
saved me I'll be working on a project
and something just won't look quite
right on my data and my predictions and
then I plot it and I go oh wow that is
just too perfect of a fit and I look
back at my date and I say well it's
because I'm fitting the answer to the
answer that sounds very odd but it does
happen you would be amazed when you get
into some of the deep coding which you
can do with your predictions and your
sidekick so in this case we're just
going to do a simple plot and the simple
plot is in the format of X or X comma Y
so these are all our X values we'll do 1
2 3 4 and these are our Y values 1 2 3 4
what's important to note here is 1 we're
importing the mat plot library dot pie
plot as PLT PLT once we put it in here
this creates a basically a canvas that
you're painting on so you can plot all
kinds of stuff on here and you won't see
anything until you do
PLT show and so when you do PLT dot show
then will display that graph and let me
go ahead and run that and take a look
and see what that does and of course we
have a module error because this is a
new environment or a new project and
you'll see it even highlighted in red up
here and if you remember from that we
can go under settings once we're under
settings and our project interpreter we
see numpy up there add the plus and then
we need to import mat plot library
there's our mat plot library we're going
to install this package which takes it
just a moment and once it's done it
peers on the bottom it says package
properly installed or what it actually
says is installed successfully once you
have that we can close out of here we
can close out of our settings you need
to click OK on the bottom or you exit
out either one is fine and now if we go
ahead and run this and we'll start it
over again since I had an error PyCharm
it'll pop up with a nice figure and you
can see our plot there 1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4
and when you are working with the pie
plot library remember that
sending this works really good with
number because you can reshape it a lot
of times you'll end up with your data 1
comma 1 2 comma 3 and you have to
reformat it to 1 comma 2 comma 3 comma 4
your X and your Y plots and if we're
gonna do numpy and Matt plot library the
next one is to import pandas as PD so
you have a nice data frame in pycharm
again is highlighted in red so we need
to go up here and either set up our
project interpreter and up to the plus
sign on the right and let's go ahead and
install pandas and here's our pandas
right at the top so we'll go ahead and
install that package and then you have
to wait just a moment for the package
successfully installed and once we see
that successfully installed and good and
close out and either ok or exit out and
we're back into our pandas and then
pandas is such a wonderful data frame
set up one of the nice things about it
besides being an excellent displaying of
information and data and let some
manipulation you can do it's also makes
it really easy to import and export
information I actually have like a file
called cars here I'm going to go ahead
and copy the address to it so here's our
address and if you remember the backward
slash we either have to do double slash
or change it to a forward slash so just
do that really quick this is for this
video we're working on so it's in my
simply learned videos pycharm forward
slash this case it's cars dot CSV and
we're gonna change this into a string so
we can pull our data from here let's do
it this way now in some editors you can
highlight and just do brackets I'm
actually gonna do a ctrl X type in our
de notre for a string and then just
paste it right in because I'm very lazy
I try to do as many as few clicks as I
can let's set path equal to this ends in
the cars dot CSV because that's the file
and once we have that we can go ahead
and DF go PD read underscore CSV we have
our full path and that will just print
we'll do a full print of our data frame
you can do DF head-tail there's all
kinds of different tools to sort and
process your data frame let's go ahead
and run this and you can see here it has
261 rows and 8 columns it print out and
since I like to see what it looks
on the top will do head which does the
first five rows and you can see right
here we have our MPG cylinders cubic
inches horsepower weights / pounds etc
all the different data pulls in on this
and it puts it in a nice readable rows
and column set up so we covered the
basics of PyCharm today we went from the
website where we downloaded it up here
you can see from JetBrains underneath
the community version which is complete
open source and free to use we went in
and learned about our settings where you
can set up your different modules
different ways to get into it the
different ways to run code where to go
ahead and install the modules like
pandas and numpy that don't come as a
default remember pipe lot and math do
come as a default no pipe lot doesn't
just math comes as a default so we
learned where to install all these
different modules from we've run our
basic code we've shown you how to do the
debugger how to add a flag at the
beginning how to rename your variables
and refactor them so if you want to
rename it all the way through and we
walk through the basic running of the
programs in the debug run thank you for
joining us today for pycharm if you have
any questions feel free to add them to
the notes below in the YouTube videos we
do have people who monitor those
comments and try to reply to them you
can also visit us at simply learn com
get certified get ahead hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here